hey what's going on everybody just so
everybody knows I now have a link for
you down in the description that way
everyone can have multiple entries if
you choose to participate in the
giveaway which is going to be the
complete Game of Thrones series on
blu-ray one of you will run all six
seasons that have been released so far
just subscribe to this channel and like
this video and once you are finished
watching this video go and click the
link provided in the description and
just follow those steps thank you and
good luck so now that that's out of the
way let's get things started and today I
want to talk about Arya Stark in a
possible storyline she could be given
next season while she works her way up
the Winterfell in this video is going to
be somewhat of a continuation of my last
Arya Stark video in which I explained
how she can be given some of the story
that Lady Stoneheart has in the books so
check out the other one too if you'd
like it may give you some extra details
and context to her story but I do
realize that not all of you have read
the books and in fact someone just asked
me the other day what barracks kiss of
life meant so let me go over who exactly
Lady Stoneheart is real quick and why I
think Arya Stark is in position to
follow some of her story in the show so
all of you should remember the red
wedding which is arguably one a game of
Thrones most popular episodes where
Catelyn Stark Robb Stark and his wife
and unborn child were set up by Walder
Frey Roose Bolton in Tywin Lannister to
be executed during the slaughter lady
Catelyn had her throat slit which was
the very last image we got in that
episode but in the books the events that
followed the red wedding went down a
little bit differently in the books
after lady Catelyn had her throat slit
they then dumped her body into the river
where her body would remain for the next
three days until arias Dyer was 9 mariya
discovered her body 9 area had been
running loose and around this area
ever since Arya made her run off so she
wouldn't be killed since she had bitten
Joffrey and after 9 area discovers lady
Caitlin's dead body the Brotherhood
without banners notice and starts to
approach and that's when Nymeria runs
off again beric Dondarrion decides that
he's going to exchange his life for hers
so he gives her what is known as
the last kiss or the kiss of life he
kisses lady Catelyn and then he drops
dead and they Somme be like person who
is the artist formerly known as lady
Catelyn Rises who is now known as Lady
Stoneheart in the books and all the lady
Catelyn is now alive
she still looks like a corpse her body
is mutilated with the wide gap in her
throat where it had been slit during the
red wedding and it nearly destroyed her
ability to speak now she has to put her
hand over her slit throat in order to be
able to say anything which is still not
very clear but she remembers what
happened to her and her family at the
red wedding and she is pissed and
fuelled with vengeance which is now her
sole purpose to continue on with the way
that she is and looks and now that beric
Dondarrion is dead after giving her the
kiss of life Lady Stoneheart takes
command of the group of outlaws known as
the Brotherhood without banners and she
is ready to blaze a path of death and
destruction Lady Stoneheart in the
brotherhood are now on a mission to
execute anyone associated with the
phrase the Lannisters and the Bolton's
especially their family members and if
you thought Catelyn Stark was the [ __ ]
before Lady Stoneheart is even worse she
is brutally unforgiving they start their
vengeance tour by killing a few phrase
and that's when she eventually comes
across Brienne of Tarth and prods retain
Jaime Lannister had sent Brienne out to
find Sansa which she tells lady Catelyn
aka Lady Stoneheart which was a big
mistake Lady Stoneheart labels Brienne a
traitor who is now supporting and
working for Jaime Lannister Brienne is
still carrying the sword Oathkeeper a
Valyrian steel sword given to her by
Jaime Lannister which was forged by half
of the remains of Ned Stark's sword Ice
Brienne promises that she is still
faithful to House Stark but Lady
Stoneheart isn't moved by her words she
wants proof Lady Stoneheart demands
brand that she must kill Jaime Lannister
in order to prove her loyalty but
Brienne refuses of course saying that
Jaime Lannister is not the man that
everyone thinks he is it's obvious that
Brienne loves Jaime which is a
problem can she be trusted when push
comes to shove if bran had to choose
between saving a Stark or saving Jaime
Lannister she cannot be trusted to save
the Stark and Lady Stoneheart tells bran
you either kill Jaime or you will be
hanged for treason and branches the
refuse still so now it's obvious that
she cannot be trusted what seals her own
fate Lady Stoneheart hangs Brienne pile
and Podrick and as they are struggling
for air struggling to survive brand
screams out a single word changing her
mind right before her death so my
question is how much a Lady Stoneheart
story from the books will Arya get we
all hoped and wish that the show would
introduce the character Lady Stoneheart
but it looks like the time to introduce
our character has came and went but it's
not too late to take pieces of her story
from the books and give it to another
Stark which it seems like they have
already been doing with Arya in my
opinion and this wouldn't be new for the
show they have taken many stories from
the books and gave them to different
characters and who better to pick up
Lady Stoneheart story than Arya Stark
who is already on a vengeance tour of
her own killing every phrase she comes
in contact with which is absolutely
beautiful in a dark and twisted sort of
way but it is justice and justice is
beautiful especially for the Starks who
have been seemingly double-crossed by
everyone and if you consider where arias
story left off I think there is a very
good chance we can see her go down this
road for a few episodes Arya is already
near the Brotherhood without banners in
Brienne and Podrick are headed back
north themselves so you never know what
we might just get next season and after
what are you just saw she's going to
want to murder any Lannister or
Lannister supporter she can get her
hands on
when we drive our sword to our enemy's
heart may we speak the words of our
alliance the trade and the Lannisters
send their regards
[Applause]
aurilla just saw Jaime Lannister and
Walder Frey toasting with each other
celebrating the fact that they just took
over her mother Catelyn Stark's
ancestral home and killed her uncle the
blackfish Orion knows for a fact that
the Lannisters are in bed with the Freys
she just saw it for herself and even
gave Jaime a suspicious look and later
that night she slit Walder Frey's throat
for conspiracy and murder against her
family and she's blood thirsty for more
Jaime wasn't on her list but you bet
your ass he is now and who is the one
person that's worth fealty for a stark
but continues to have a friendly
relationship with the enemy no paper no
as he sold you got there where'd he get
it I've been looking at Lannister gold
all my life go on Brienne of [ __ ]
Tarth tell me that's not Lannister gold
Jaime Lannister gave me the sword
the buddy gates 10 miles I swore to your
mother by the old I don't have what you
bring and is carrying around that
[ __ ] Lannister gold given to her by
Jaime Lannister a sworn enemy of the
Starks Orion owes the Lannisters had her
father killed she saw Cersei standing
next to Joffrey and her father smiling
as his head was about to be taken off
Arya knows Tywin Lannister was at war
with her brother Robb Stark which he
ultimately set up at the red wedding and
had executed how was are you going to
react when she runs into brenigan
and she is still carrying around that
[ __ ] Lannister sword will she ever be
able to trust her she was sworn to
protect her mother and she failed I
asked if you wanted something I thought
your mother was bringing hunter my
mother is dead
I know I wish I could have been there to
protect her yeah I know the nurse but I
swore a sacred vow to protect why didn't
you
[Music]
now that REO will be heading home after
she cleans house at the phrase there is
a very good chance she runs into the
Brotherhood without banners again who
are now with the hound
if Arya gets to with the Hound in the
Brotherhood and they wanted to bring and
Podrick
I can see trouble on the horizon the
hound already tried to kill her once
what's Brienne going to say she helped
Sansa Arya doesn't even like Sansa that
won't be enough to prove that she isn't
working for the Lannisters and Arya
might give her the same ultimatum her
mother gave her in the books you go kill
Jaime Lannister or I'll hang you and
that [ __ ] Podrick in your honor will be
forgotten and you'll forever be known as
a traitor to the Starks that would make
for a very tough decision for brand
honor compels me to sites with tons of
kin of course it does
to fight you
that's how we dozen come from
[Music]
I think if the show went this route it
would be amazing brand being forced to
kill Jamie what a plot twist there
hasn't been much of any information
about Brenda's all season so I think her
story next season can go in a number of
directions and I would be happy as hell
if they did this and Arya is definitely
crazy enough and loves her family enough
to make sure bran gets this done but if
accordingly if you kill me to fail
they'd be stuck let's don't go I'm going
to kill you
good thank you but good comment below
and tell me what you think about this
personally I think this would be amazing
and I haven't heard anyone else discuss
this as a possibility yet in the show so
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
let's talk about this but before I go if
you guys have time go and check out sir
hunts reviews channel he has a ton of
Game of Thrones content on his channel
and me and him have been discussing some
things lately and we plan on doing a
stream together too so if you aren't
familiar with him go check out his
channel and say what's up also don't
forget to check out the link below so
you can enter the giveaway thank you
guys and I will see you in the comment
section bye